scp-682 vs scp-513  sometimes to take down a scary scp like  scp-682 you need to bring in an even  scarier scp like this demonic cowbell  and the phantom it reveals  scp-682 was partially incinerated and  brought into a testing chamber where a  robotic arm rang the scp-513 bell  several times with the resulting sound  causing extreme stress for scp-682  aerosolized tranquilizers and sedatives  were pumped into the chamber causing 682  to fall unconscious it then began  sleepwalking breaching the containment  chamber but it wasn't alone a  nightmarish ghost-like entity resembling  682 began stalking the halls after mass  hysteria and mass staff death across the  site the foundation finally got things  back under control when scp-682 was  woken up it complained saying it was  having such a lovely dream